[Music]
we live in a time where specialized AI
technologies enable us to develop legal
autonomous weapons lethal autonomous
weapons really means a weapons that are
meant to kill humans and without a human
intervention lethal autonomous weapons
could locate identify and kill their
targets without any input from a person
these weapons would react too fast for a
human to maintain meaningful control
they could be mass-produced and
programmed to target innocent civilians
of a specific ideology and they could be
made small enough to enable the
assassination of any political leader AI
technologies cannot capture human
judgments and ethical rules that are
essentially making decisions concerning
life and death thousands of AI
researchers from around the world agree
we must take the opportunity to ban
lethal autonomous weapons now once we
have decided collectively it's not
morally acceptable use the technology
that is the first step to ridding the
world of this horror current AI is too
stupid to really have the sort of
understanding of the social context of
psychological context and and even you
know more generally human morality so if
you want an AI that can play a game or
can recognize objects and images we can
do that that that's possible but there's
nothing that gives human-like judgement
or intelligence I think it's really
dangerous to assume that automation is
in fact more objective or more clean or
you know more life-saving as people
often claim
it is still impossible for a
computational system to be able to
identify in a situated context what
constitutes a valid target we can't
build autonomous weapons that follow
international humanitarian law and they
would let a scale warfare in a way just
remised war friend away that can only be
compared to other weapons of mass
destruction one program I could do what
previously took thousands of soldiers to
do once they're out then it's gonna be
much easier for small actors not not
even governments necessarily to use them
in nefarious ways which could have an
impact on the mauka scene freedom speech
artificial intelligence systems when
exposed to new kinds of inputs they tend
to behave in very unpredictable ways so
if we start seeing that on the
battlefield which is one of the most
chaotic and unpredictable environments
that you could imagine from where your
enemies are actively trying to subvert
your systems we don't know what will
happen if we proceed with lethal
autonomous weapons we make our own worst
nightmare come true unlike nuclear
biological or chemical weapons lethal
autonomous weapons can be developed
cheaply with easy to find materials and
they can more easily be hacked or fall
into the wrong hands right this is why
it takes you know massive numbers of
engineer and data center staff for all
of these large companies to maintain
operations because these things break
because complex systems are fallible if
you're trying to secure a system you
must be successful every single time
every single minute of every single day
you must be successful in securing that
system against everything if you are
attacking that system you only need to
be successful once and now the system
has been breached we need to ban lethal
autonomous weapons immediately before
the arms race becomes irreversible it's
not just common sense to ban machines
that can decide to kill humans it's
essential for at the sake of
international security
I'm not worried that a ban will hinder
research in fact I'm worried that we
don't have a ban it will in the research
that the technology was stigmatized and
all the good things even the good things
that the military can use AI like
clearing minefields and dropping
supplies into contested territory those
won't happen because the public will
turn against the use of the technology
in all aspects of our lives if we don't
put a ban then there could easily be a
backlash in the public opinion against
AI research in general
artificial intelligence should be used
to save and to improve lives I use
artificial intelligence to program
robots that can help people with chronic
illnesses have a better quality of life
if we want artificial intelligence to be
a force for good in the world we need to
ban bad uses of AI we need to stop
weaponizing this technology I'd like the
UN to negotiate a ban on lethal
autonomous weapons I support the ban on
lethal autonomous weapons we need to ban
lethal autonomous weapons immediately I
support a ban on lethal autonomous
weapons we should all oppose new
autonomous weapons we must take the
opportunity to ban lethal autonomous
weapons and we must ensure a AI is used
to create a better world
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]